we were first introduced to dante bishop
on march 21 2022 in southern california
he's homeless and he's being stalked by
a group of purgers who describe
themselves as fine young very educated
guys and gals they wear creepy brown
masks and fancy clothes it's not known
why they target him but it's entirely
possible that being homeless he thought
he'd fare better hiding in an upscale
residential neighborhood whose residents
are less likely to be on the streets for
their purge than those in the inner city
but his assumption was sadly mistaken
when he encountered their group
and just happened to be the first
homeless person they came across they
have a mission to take
out the homeless in the lower class
because wiping out that demographic
means paying less on taxes that support
things like food stamps and homeless
shelters it's clear based on the way
they talk about him that they look down
on the homeless
the man you're sheltering is nothing but
a dirty homeless pig a grotesque menace
to our just society who had the audacity
to fight back
so when the group encounters dante they
see that he's homeless and they go after
him but things don't go as expected to
learn about how dante's experiences that
night were instrumental in putting a
stop to the purge once and for all
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to horror history today's
episode will break down one of the most
unlikely characters to become a hero in
the world of the purge when he was first
introduced edwin hodge's character only
spoke on maybe four separate occasions
and was known in the credits simply as
bloody stranger
then in anarchy he makes a small
appearance but this time he isn't bloody
so he's just credited as the stranger
it isn't until the third movie that we
learn who he is and how his experiences
changed history so to understand his
story let's take it back to just before
he shows up for the first time in the
series
surrounded by this strange group of
gussied-up purge participants he
surprises them by fighting back he
probably did this with a knife that he
had with him and he actually manages to
purge one of them
after doing this he runs for it i
imagine the purgers were too busy
tending to their friends to bother going
after him right away but they would soon
follow him with revenge in mind
dante runs down the street in a gated
residential community and tries to call
out for help to the local residents
his prayers are answered when the sandon
household lifts their security and a
young boy yells out to him he makes a
sprint for it and manages to slide under
the closing door just in time
he may be safe from his original
attackers however for all he knows the
sandon family is also looking to purge
him they have blue batisias outside a
sign that they support the purge but not
necessarily a sign that they participate
in the purge themselves taking shelter
is dante's best bet but he still has to
stay on his toes it quickly becomes
apparent that this kid was the only one
reason that he was led inside when the
parents emerge in a state of anger and
confusion
the dad slowly draws his gun on dante
but his focus is diverted when a young
man on the stairs opens fire on mr
sanden the distraction gives dante a
chance to escape and hide in the house
he's probably planning on trying to
avoid the family until the purge ended
the next morning but he realizes the
family isn't his only concern when the
power is cut in the entire house
as he's searching for a spot he nearly
gets caught when mr sanden shines a
flashlight on him with his gun drawn
the darkness works to dante's advantage
here and he's able to disappear once
more he ducks out behind a couch in a
living room when he's approached by a
strange drone shaped like a creepy
deformed baby doll when it spots him
nobody comes running to his location to
capture him so he's intrigued by what
its purpose is and decides to follow it
perhaps thinking it was being controlled
by the boy that led him inside
if that was his logic he would have been
correct it leads him to a closet where
he discovers a hidden area covered up by
a panel and he takes refuge there just
before mrs sandin enters the room she
searches the closet and he readies his
knife but ultimately is not discovered
that doesn't last long however because
the sandin's daughter zoe also tries to
hide there and not wanting to kill
anyone dante has no choice but to take
her hostage the threat doesn't really
work out for him though because he was
never going to shoot zoe he's not
violent by nature and killing her
wouldn't get him anywhere
in a standoff with mr sandin he explains
that he doesn't want to hurt any of them
but he deserves to survive the night
just as much as they do he finds out
that the purge group that he escaped
from threatened the sandons lives if
they don't turn him back over
meanwhile mrs sandin sneaks up behind
him and he has to abandon his plan
he throws zoe into the wall and tries to
run for it but he's brought down by mr
sanding he flails and struggles but is
forced to cooperate when mr sandon
restrains him and his wife brutally cuts
into his wound with a letter opener
dante is duct taped to a chair where he
sees how much turmoil he's causing the
family and
concedes his struggle
savior children take me outside
it is perhaps this humility that causes
mr sandon to decide that he's had enough
of being pushed around by the purgers
outside the house he leaves dante and
restrains upstairs unsupervised giving
him time to wiggle out and free himself
once again he hides somewhere in the
house as he hears the sandon family
fight for their lives and his own
at some point he must have felt guilty
for hiding while the man who risked
everything for him
a stranger was being massacred
downstairs and he decides that he's
going to return the favor the other
neighbors take care of the threat of the
mass purge group but only because they
want to take the sandins out
themselves dante finds himself a weapon
and the controller for the creepy baby
drone and just as the neighbors are
about to sacrifice the family he runs
the rc vehicle across the foyer to
distract everyone allowing him to get
into position and go to town on the
neighbors knocking the first one out
with his fist taking out another with
his gun
and grabbing the woman grace as a
hostage he forces the remaining
neighbors to drop their weapons and
untie the remainder of the family but
once they're safe he refuses to engage
in any more violence he watches over
everyone as they sit at the kitchen
table and wait for the purge to expire
after the siren sound dante is the last
to leave he places the gun on the table
and when mary thanks him for saving them
all he can muster is
the psychological damage of the horrors
he experienced that night would change
the course of the rest of dante's life
he had seen firsthand what the purge was
doing to his country and his new mission
would be to put a stop to it
sometime over the next year he joins an
anti-purge revolutionary group headed up
by a man named carmelo johns carmelo's
thesis is that the purge is a tool to
funnel wealth upward to the nffa
political party through killing he aims
to educate people about that and protect
those who would be victims this makes a
perfect organization for dante to be a
part of given that his lack of wealth in
2022 gave him no way to protect himself
and that nearly resulted in him being
purged
this year we will fight back during the
2023 purge carmelo's group hacks into
the nffa countdown stream at the six
hour mark and issues a propaganda
warning claiming that their message will
be written in the blood of their
opponents this shows us that dante's
views have changed since the previous
year
when he was only willing to engage in
violence for survival purposes this year
he'd be coming
fully armed
[Music]
the anti-nffa revolutionary group led by
carmelo john spends their 2023 purge
trying to find and break up an nffa
purge night gala where rich political
donors have the option to buy into a
controlled environment where they can
shoot down unarmed victims for sports
dante is a part of this mission which
requires him to break one of the few
laws upheld during the purge
using class 5 weapons and above in this
case explosives that help them gain
entry to the building
dante leads the way striking down the
nffa security guards and announcing to
the victims that they're here to help
and that they should hold their fire
he's also the first one to reach them
and explain who they are and what
they're doing there
nobody's special there's some people who
don't necessarily agree with the purge
at all
he recommends that they get out before
things get nasty and carmelo's group
forms a line and combs the room taking
out everyone associated with the nfa
since dante's identity was not covered
it's likely that he had to go into
hiding to avoid being arrested for his
use of high-class explosives it may also
be possible that it was too dark in
there for any cameras to pick up his
identity or that he actually was
prosecuted for the illegal use of
explosives but was eventually released
from prison however i find that idea
pretty unlikely based on the fact that
in the world of the purge trespassing
after the siren sound gets you the death
penalty
so it's pretty hard to imagine the
penalty for using illegal weapons would
be any less
it's not known what happened to carmelo
johns but at some point bishop assumes
leadership of the anti-nffa militia and
brings out a man named angel to be his
second in command
during his time in charge of the
organization he sets up a series of
underground triage centers staffed with
doctors and medical supplies meant as an
alternate form of protest against what
goes on during the purge
he also invites the homeless to take
shelter there likely in honor of charlie
sanden who offered him shelter when he
was on the streets
17 years after breaking up the gala
dante finds himself in washington dc at
the heart of a protest against the purge
in the year 2040. the nffa this year is
facing the greatest threat to the purge
yet because a new political candidate
named charlie rohn has gained enough
popularity to threaten the nffa's regime
that's why dante has taken his talents
to the nation's capital where he gives a
statement on the 11 o'clock news
for the past 20 years the nffa has taken
a legalized murder to decrease
the poor population which in turn keeps
the government spending down
less welfare less health care less
housing
feeling threatened by senator rohn the
nffa institutes a new law that removes
the exemption for high-ranking
government officials just as dante once
tried to use the sandin family's own
weapons against them he sees this as an
opportunity to take out the nffa's next
presidential candidate edward jones he
watches a presidential debate where he
learns that owens will be spending this
year's purge at a part religious cults
part political cult ceremony called the
midnight purge mass and bishop and his
team of revolutionaries planned to break
in and assassinate him ensuring rhone
the presidential victory
the nffa has created predatory
capitalism where profit making
is the essence of democracy
we've come to dc to make some changes on
purge night bishop's base of operations
is one of the underground triage centers
which is supposed to be secure because
only the triage van drivers know its
location
call this a safe zone bishop gets word
that an attempt was made on senator
rohn's life and that she'll be taking
refuge in his safe zone
he shows her around and helps her get
settled in and vows to use his armed men
to keep her safe
she does thank him for his protection
but also confronts him about some of the
tactics he employs on purginai that she
doesn't agree with she's probably
referring to the group's tendency to
fight violence with violence he tells
her that if she gets elected and puts an
end to purge night he won't have to do
those things anymore
however he's not planning on leaving the
results of that election up to chance
this plan gets exposed when senator
rohn's private security detail leo
barnes one of the men that bishop saved
in 2023 goes behind closed doors and
discovers their plot to take down edward
johans
rhone vehemently objects claiming that
her opponent must survive to lose the
election otherwise he may become a
martyr and risk further civil
retaliation
nfa soldiers discover and storm the safe
zone looking for dante but he's already
gone when they arrive
he and his men are infiltrating a secret
underground tunnel into the cathedral
where owens's midnight purge mass is
being held
they encounter an unexpected ally it's
leo barnes the man in charge of keeping
senator rohn alive he explains that
she's been kidnapped by the nffa and
that this is now a rescue mission
barnes and his allies joined dante's
team in the invasion they split up so
that barnes takes the vantage point at
the balcony and bishop and his men
enter from behind the altar barnes's
people are able to get off the perfect
shot to save the senator but they're
countered by a wave of secret service
agents which dante and his people catch
by surprise by coming up behind them it
looks as if he may have remembered
something he learned 18 years ago at the
sandon house
his troops also capture minister owens
and rhone begs him to reconsider taking
out her political rival
i can win without this relax you will
win
i'm gonna make sure that when she tries
to say that going through with it will
make him no different than the nfa he
tells his people to seize her which
leads to a standoff between barnes and
bishop he brushes her off and goes into
the room where owens is being kept at
this point the minister is encouraging
and begging him to purge it
knowing that the political ripple effect
of his death would benefit the nffa
gonte finds himself on the other end of
the situation that he was in in 2022
and like his captor mr sandin dante
makes the decision not to use violence
to lower himself to the level of the
purgers and his parting words to rhone
are that she better win that election
they continue on to the next chamber
where owens has dozens of prisoners who
would have been purged if midnight purge
mass had not been broken up but bishop
is more concerned with leading the
charge out of the church to get rone to
safety they make it to the parking lot
where they come up against a group of
mercenaries led by the neo-nazi nffa
henchmen earl danzinger denzinger's
squad completely overpowers them in
terms of firepower he has several men
firing away big automatic weapons they
take out two of dante's top guys and
shoot him in the hand
leo comes to his aid and dante asks him
to cover him while he tries one last
move he hotwires a car and floors it
across the garage to take out two of the
evil mercenaries but
as soon as he does so he is shot dead by
dancing it is likely that without dante
bishop's heroics leo and the others
would have had no chance to defeat
danzinger get senator rohn and edward
jones to safety and ultimately two
months later on may 26 defeat the nffa
in the presidential election
and finally put an end to the nationwide
purge after at least
23 years was dante bishop perfect not by
any means
right when we first meet him he's a
killer but we can see at the beginning
it's only out of desperation
to survive and he does everything he can
to avoid unnecessary death
that night he takes one more life in
order to save three innocent ones
however he does let the experience shape
him in a negative way the following
purge he once again saves a group of
people but he allows carmelo's vengeful
ways to influence him and he stays
behind to do more fighting rather than
help the survivors get to safety in the
years that would follow it's implied
that he does a lot of good with his
organization by helping the injured and
the homeless but he gets a mixed
reputation
based on how he goes about things also i
mean we can't just look past the fact
that he automatically knew how to
hotwire a car i mean he's obviously up
to some shady stuff but overall he did
have good intentions and he played a
vital part in stopping
the nffa and the purge if he and carmelo
hadn't saved leo barnes in 2023 and leo
never would have been there to protect
senator rohn in 2040.
and if he hadn't sacrificed himself in
2040 who knows if she would have
survived let me know in the comments if
there are any other purge characters
you'd like to see covered here on horror
history and if you love the purge i've
got plenty more purge videos on the way
so check out that playlist on the left
and remember to subscribe to cz's world
for new horrors every week ring the
death bell for notifications and i'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
and just like the purge i recommend you
stay home but if you have to go out
wear a mask